the payoff i think at the end of this is
enormous for fans that have really been
watching the marvel
payoff is huge we are an unusual couple
you know
oh i don't think that was ever in
question there's so many things that i
loved about this it
so wasn't what i expected it to be but i
wonder how was it for you
like stepping into this kind of 50
sitcom era shooting it
in front of a live audience like a
sitcom it's it seems like it's like the
least
marvel thing that that would happen with
a franchise how was that for you
it was really exciting marvel's taking a
huge
swing they've always been rewarded for
taking
you know these impossibly big swings i
think it's very easy
to forget what a big risk john favreau
and robert downey jr were to
to start this whole thing and you know
the the
the show starts with
wonder and vision dropped into a sort of
idyllic
american suburban uh
sitcom and and starts hurtling
through the decades you'll see that
vision
starts to think wait a second what that
what is
what's going on in this town why why
we're in the 70s you know what what
what what's happening and something
can't be right here and then
the world that we've come to know and
love
the mcu and and this world as we move
through the 50s 60s 70s
80s 90s the north we
they start to collide and the payoff i
think at the end of this
is enormous for fans that have really
been watching the marvel
playoff is huge and also i hope it
brings in through the sort of nostalgia
of those old shows that we
lovingly recreated um
some some uh some new some new uh
some new fans you know another risk that
that marvel is taking here
with all of that as well is we know you
know marvel to be so
top secret like we get nothing and then
you're shooting in front of this like
live audience so people are seeing
what's happening i'm like whoa why
couldn't i have been
people had to sign some very very strict
non-disclosure
agreements um so uh
yeah that felt very weird that felt very
weird actually the whole thing felt
weird i was very nervous
and and uh you know
dug my heels and i didn't want to do it
in front of the live studio and so
i hadn't been in front of an audience
for 20 years i was scared and
um but they insisted and we did it and
what was amazing was you really got the
quality of those
that those shows
you can feel the audience in the room
you can feel that the actors
are projecting to to to something beyond
the camera and um
and it was really helpful plus
once you've done that lizzie and i and
catherine we weren't nervous about
anything anymore
we just felt fearless to really go there
the aesthetics of the 50s i i think it
was so cool like it was so cool to see
elizabeth in
you know the the kind of donna reid
looking
um aesthetic and even her voice you know
because the voices then were different
what was your favorite part of that
aesthetic because you did go through the
decades too
with different i i think it was really
fun tracking all of those if you
you you start off in in this with the
warmth of the dick van dyke show then
you get into
um the witch show and remember in the
witch show
she's a super powerful witch and he's
always embarrassed by her power
he the man is embarrassed by his wife's
power and is always telling her to
suppress her power right and then you
get into the brady bunch
where the vietnam war is raging and yet
they're having
and then you get into the 80s with the
source of slightly saccharine
family ties teachable moments tom hanks
turns up he's the uncle he's a bit of a
drunk
and it's a teachable moment for the kids
right and then you get into the
cynicism of malcolm in the middle
and then the really quite cold cynicism
of
modern family and it's really
fascinating to see all of those
different styles and our acting styles
and what you know studying all of those
uh
shows and it was really fun bringing
them um back to life from
this show you know we're in a new normal
of course 2020 was
woof of a year 2021 hasn't given us much
of a reprieve yet
um we're in these unprecedented times
but i'm so thankful for
all the content that we're getting in
whatever form that we're getting it
um what do you think about this kind of
new normal rollout
that we're getting and and how much we
are saturating
the streaming services because i know i
i
one of the things that it's a bit
trivial but i just miss going to the
movies and going to see a big
blockbuster at the movies so much yes
i i mean remember this was always
pitched as a
tv uh uh show an experiment
i think that what's interesting about
marvel is that they've been sort of
experimenting with breaking down what we
usually expect from a movie with a
three-act structure and
in actual fact the whole of marvel i
suppose you could argue has been one
huge and extravagant tv exercise because
it's an episodic formula
there are spin-offs and then those
spin-offs all come together and
i've never seen that on film it's always
been on tv that that sort of thing has
happened you know we all come together
for the avengers but there are these
different franchises and
the barrier between tv and phil which
has always been
has been getting more and more
intangible
has really been broken through with this
this is part of the same world
and the same universe that said
i agree with you and i miss
all sorts of things i miss restaurants i
miss pubs
touching people that i'm not married to
just
in a weird way but you know just like
hey how are you doing right
and i can't wait for it and i can't wait
for communal shared experiences like
going to the
um theater and the cinema and and
and i believe in my bones
that we will have it back well speaking
of people you're married to
20 years marks uh the anniversary of one
of my favorite films that you worked on
with your wife jennifer connolly a
beautiful mind
uh that anniversary is coming up i just
wonder i heard a little
little um little something that you
actually had a crush on her even before
you met her was that true
oh yeah that's true yeah but you know
i'm not i don't think i'm alone in that
i think
you know i mean how old you're not by
the way
i mean what 13 year old boy didn't have
a crush on jennifer connolly and
when they saw labyrinth um you know so
so that is abs
that's i'm afraid and you know at the
risk of sounding like
the longest most successful stalker
there has ever been
i yeah i did i i did kind of um
i was quite taken my yeah my young 13
year old
self was you know she was very um it's
quite taken but they uh
yeah yeah what do you remember about
being on set with her at that time
when i first saw her at the read-through
i remember saying to myself
i've never been this close to somebody
that beautiful that's the truth i didn't
think that
and i thought i bet everybody that she's
ever every man she's ever met has tried
to flirt with us so i'm gonna
absolutely not and instead i remember
this distinctly we talked politics
and the rest is history i love
i love i love thank you for giving me a
little brightness a little hope and love
on this saturday morning i stand that
thank you so much paul um i really love
this
series and and i can't wait to be able
to see the rest of it so
thank you so much